un bacio beh fino ai sentito anche tu
[Musica]
e pighi giornata appena una colla in
mano
sicuramente vuol dire che vuole che
troviamo tutti gli ingredienti slime per
scacciarla spero solo che non sia già
rientrate in casa berlino e sentito
dobbiamo andare a trovare tutti gli
ingredienti sprime mi aiuterai benvenuti
sanità stories
io sono unità e lui e merlino oggi nuova
avventura nuova challenge righi è
tornata purtroppo se vi ricordate bene
ho già sconfitto pighi nel video in cui
giochiamo pighi nella realtà se non
l'avete visto andate a vederlo dopo
questo video stavolta dovrà trovare
tutti gli ingredienti slime per
scacciare picchi di casa ma ovviamente
non devo essere presa per più di cinque
volte altrimenti avrò perso la challenge
se volete vedere altri video trova agli
ingredienti slimer lasciate un bel mi
piace su questo video e se questo video
raggiunge i 40 mila mi piace il prossimo
episodio sarà è una sorpresa nella
sorpresa chi sarà il prossimo episodio
per questa volta voglio farvi una
sorpresa e non voglio dirvi chi sarà il
prossimo personaggio quindi lasciate un
bel mi piace su questo video
prendete i pop corn e mettetevi comodi e
iniziamo la nostra challenge berlino sei
pronta a trovare tutti gli ingredienti
slime mi devi il tar e mi raccomando
soprattutto se senti l'odore di picchi o
stenti che si sta avvicinando aiuta
migliaio bisogni ok mi raccomando non si
resti dalla parte di pighi come hai
fatto con grandi lo prendo come un sì
ora iniziamo la ricerca vediamo senso
che qui in camera
stiamo molto attenti in tempo
mi sono spaventata perchè ho visto una
cosa rosa ma era semplicemente la mia
maglietta
se qualcosa di rosa sotto al letto
sbaglio si che cos'è la paletta e
ovviamente rosa come pighi quindi
abbiamo già il nostro brevissimo
ingrediente bene continuiamo la nostra
esplorazione o no prendi lo studio di
chico sotto letto forse vivere qua
[Musica]
berlino ciao grazie per avermi svegliato
con tutti questi bozzini e paletta forse
non riuscita a recuperare la paletta
anche se picchi mi ha preso è sveglia
sveglia sveglia guarda ho perso una vita
purtroppo quindi me ne rimangono solo 4
però ho già un ingrediente che non è
proprio un ingrediente più un accessorio
che un ingrediente
lascia berlino lascia bravo bravissimo
questo ingrediente l'ha preso merlino no
io bene ragazzi abbiamo la soluzione
perdenti grazie a berlino è stato
bravissimo a berlino non polis a perché
sono una scossa qua ok ok ragazzi sono
dentro un armadio
non vedo picchi ecco la ix aprile va in
una pianura
vedremo che è stato fatto
a berlino bastati sposati se la si
accorge che sono qua
berlino vino berlino sta entrando dentro
l'armadio ora pd mi scoprirà di sicuro è
sceso togliti dai marlino ti prego
spostati è andato via per fortuna è
andata via via libera a berlino
siamo liberi siamo riusciti a scamparla
per un pelo
ora vado a portare la soluzione perfetti
in studio ok ora che abbiamo due
ingredienti continuiamo la nostra
ricerca berlino perché ero in bagno
forse c'è qualcosa in bagno
questo bambino che strano che lo trovate
così velocemente
hai visto berlino anzitutto grazie a
merlino perché a berlino era in bagno
non so cosa stesse annusando in bagno e
quindi mi ha fatto trovare il mio
carbonato bravissimo berlino berlino per
chi c'è il bicarbonato
ma no perso un'altra vita con peggy
quantomeno rimangono adesso merlino bene
abbiamo perso un'altra possibilità però
abbiamo il bicarbonato si manca
solamente solamente la colla quando lei
è arrivata aveva la colla in mano quindi
sicuramente la con sé gli dobbiamo
trovare pighi non dobbiamo trovare la
colla quindi cerchiamo picchi adesso e
poi troviamo un modo per distrarla per
prenderle la colla che cessino
c'è qualcosa fa la mossa di bp che cosa
si fa
forse pure che la seguono vediamo se
riesco a prenderla avendo più su volete
stare sopra gli scali mi è venuta
un'idea anche se berlino sta già salendo
le scale perché è un curioso né prima di
salire prendo tutti gli ingredienti con
me così nel caso che pitti sia su sarò
prontissimo a fare lo slime ea farla
scomparire
ecco qua tutto il necessario ora
proviamo a salire le scale a chiocciola
anche se sono un po inquietanti
seguiamo la massa anche se non penso che
sia proprio una buona idea
però devo per forza trovare quindi per
trovare la colla
no non c'è nessuno che cosa significa
era forse una trappola questa che
generino ok ragazzi ho preso anche la
mazza ma non riesco più a tenere niente
in mano la camera ha tutti gli
ingredienti e anche la mazza quindi devo
trovare un punto per appoggiare tutte
queste cose
speriamo che pighi nomi colga di
sorpresa
ok ho contato tutto qua sul divano
merlino già entrato in questa camera
perfetto forse riesco a trovare la colla
questo che pighi stato al mondo chi no
tu
presa o no si svegliava berlino io no
aiutami a miss ferita per chi aiuta come
si apre così la prima dove vai fuori dai
cuori che iniziano fatta la gita fuori
il problema è che c'è anche berlino
fuori cache 2 forza porto uscire qui ci
crediamo sbrigarmi devo creare lo slam
bellissimamente prima che riesca ad
aprire la porta entrare premi ok un
ingrediente gli interpreti gli altri
ingredienti che sta facendo poi sco
citando un piano per entrare
il problema è che non ho la ciotola tv
assolutamente trovare una ciotola anche
spiegarmi per via fianco alla a di vita
storari ancora per fortuna non è uscita
tech con un sacco di colla correzione
parlent i puri di auto brivio voti su
gridiamo tep carbonato penso che questo
slime uscirà molto zig e eccomi pronto è
uscito un po viscido fra bubi nostra mb
pighi e rota come pt mostrare un
progressivo è impossibile però guarda te
[Musica]
per chi è riuscito ad aprire la porta
fermagli picchi guarda un po sono
riuscita a creare lo slime pighi quindi
hai perso questa challenge
ce l'abbiamo fatta abbiamo vinta dal
challenge contro fighi trova di grigi
slime nascosti da pighi ed è uscito un
gilet slime un pd slime mi raccomando
adesso che mi piace se volete un altro
episodio trova gli ingredienti slime è
ora vi lascio qua 4 caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e vuole
rischiare ciao